new munis is out in theaters people
sort of we live in california
so it's it's the theaters aren't open
out here i did see john campia
drive all the way to nevada to go watch
it good for him
i'm not gonna do that yeah i'm impressed
as much as much champion as i've been
doing for this movie to get released in
theaters because i feel like it's earned
it
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna take that
trip
i don't blame you i mean i did see that
like an hour away
that there's a drive-in that is
featuring the new mutants
35 a car to go there hey man pack 10
people in there you get your money
get all these with the cash cosplay like
it's with the cost for the amount of ac
we're going to use in this 100 degree
weather in
california right now and then all the
bodily all the respiratory fluids we're
going to build up in the car i thought
it would be fun today since we can't
watch new mutants right now
if we just reacted to the rotten
tomatoes score because reviews got to be
out honestly i did
give him some like bottom line consensus
to see what some people said jeremy
johns john campia chris stuckman
the consensus seems to be it's okay i'm
going to assume this movie
is probably between like a 55 to 65
percent on rotten tomatoes
somewhere there i'm gonna go optimistic
just to be a curveball and say 73.
all right bill and ted went up after
last night so we'll see
let's see what this is at then
i feel oddly suspenseful right now
all right here we go moment of truth
clicking the button
and the 182 people who saw
neither of these is encouraging no
oh oh i feel really bad for them
i'd take it back it should have gone to
video on demand
yeah i wonder and now i'm sitting here
doing a thought experiment in my head
going
if it went to video on demand would this
score be different and how much does
that viewing uh environment affect the
score
oh i feel so bad for this movie i mean
i'm not going to say like this is what i
feel because that would just be a lie
because i haven't seen it
but this is not going to do the movie
any favors no
it's not going to encourage anybody to
go and like drive an
hour or risk to go
out and see it this poor poor movie is
this why marvel is over
yeah is this why barbara was over his
trending on twitter yeah
yeah dc can overcome like several
horrible decisions but all it takes for
marvel is this one
offshoot that's why kevin feige's been
like hush hush and not releasing
anything
she's feeling like they're gonna release
this [ __ ] dude in this movie all
right
we're just gonna have the marvel logo
there we just need to like get it out of
the way stay quiet for a while
then we're gonna drop some awesome [ __ ]
all right this is literally gonna be the
what have you done for me lately of
marvel and that's not gonna help us when
we have nothing to release
just to be clear i don't i think marvel
is over
fans are trying to egg it on i've never
really believed in this competition
between marvel and dc
the fact that marvel's been quiet is a
good thing for them because then when
they come out with some awesome stuff
it's going to be
refreshing things that are not another
black widow trailer it's going to be
really sweet so yeah i don't agree with
the whole marvelous overthing and this
is
not hiding their time this is not uh
lumped in with the mcu we all know that
by now
the mcu is letting you understand four
seconds
oh no you're just a gc fan they're
letting you know they're like
dc pillow heads so they can come back in
with something fresh freaking
unnecessary competition playstation's
better than xbox yeah
who loses better than netflix okay oh
not even the audience score likes it
i know and i could believe this because
that's only 182 people
these are the dedicated people yeah who
are like i'm getting in that theater
oh jesus christ what are the capsule
reviews
eh um let's check it out there's only
20 reviews right now at the time of us
covering this
this comes from michael nordin from the
rap it's the kind of movie many fans
will surely want to like and while it
lives up to that modest promise it
certainly doesn't go above
and beyond i mean i kind of just wanted
it to be passable
and it's okay peter de bruges from
variety says
re-shot re-cut and somehow rescued from
total obscurity
boone's movie isn't half bad at last
it's not half good either
everyone kind of this is kind of like
what i've been hearing other people
that's okay
but i thought some of these okays would
have been enough would have been like
make it fresh yeah yeah especially when
you see like a two out of
four or a two out of five that gets a
fresh sometimes on rotten tomatoes i
love the short ones that just say
very little new here that's the
hollywood reporter jordan mintzer oh
gosh
like straight to the point so aaron
peterson from the hollywood outsider
says the new mutants benefits from an
exciting young cast and a fresh
perspective
yet the film fails to capitalize on its
full
potential that's too bad oh man we got
scott mendelsohn
that's uh that's zack snyder's best
friend his boy gotta just
gotta get that taken it's the worst
x-men movie ever
asking to watch a terrible tv pilot for
a series that you already know didn't
that's a good barb yeah cause i cuz the
problem is i can see it because
so many tv promos look like movie
trailers man this poor movie i was
really rooting for it
we might watch it and still end up
liking it we'll be honest if we do
we might um i'm not going into this
reason i'm cool with like reading
capsules or hearing like
bottom line consensus is because if i
hear specifics i feel like that'll
really
affect my viewing experience rarely do
these contain spoilers
here's some positive ones slash film oh
in a world where normal seems very
abnormal indeed to experience something
middling feels surprising
this is what i mean i thought more of
the capsules would be like
yeah it's okay it's comfortable i
recommend it you know
it's kind of different because because
the yeah the little responses i've seen
have at least credited the film for
being kind of different for a superhero
movie
well hell yeah sean chandler's got a
great youtube channel love his reviews
uh if you ever wanted the breakfast club
as a horror movie
set in the x-men universe you now have
it it may not fully live up to the
potential of that sentence but i had a
good time
with it good times are are what
you want jorge loose sir loser
didn't know if i was like a incorrect
spanish pronunciation
maybe it may not become a cult film but
it is a solid adventure film
oh it doesn't even have cult film status
that's gotta i think it has to be like
swinging for the fences to do that
yes i mean everyone's kind of saying the
same thing about it right now this is a
bummer for me
because um i've been holding out hope
that this could be a great
horror superhero film with a film that
is like being touted as only in theaters
open in theaters
when really it's like select theaters
right now it's very
it's open in the only theaters that are
open and then the theaters that are open
you can only fit like maybe half it's
like only in theaters with the most
massive asterisk you've ever seen next
to it yeah i feel like this could have
done way better as a full-on vod release
if they were going to release it if they
didn't want to keep postponing it and
even though
before all this i have been in the camp
of
you should just hold out hope man just
wait for the theaters to open
and release it just keep holding on then
they push for the theaters when i'm like
california is probably the
the biggest place where people go to the
movie theaters
it's la this is where hollywood is man
people come here all the time to get
into the film industry
you would think that they would at least
wait if you're gonna finally release
this until california new york and l.a
the biggest the biggest places where
movie theaters are
and the place where every movie has to
premiere to get like consideration
the fact that it's getting this you know
i i was hoping that the movie would at
least
be like received by critics and
audiences
in a way that was you know what it's
actually all right it's actually a
pretty cool movie
it's not great it's not amazing but it's
actually pretty cool and with no
competition it's actually kind of nice
to have it around
yeah i was really hoping that would be
the reception but
this isn't going to do it any favors
this is just going to make it more like
who's going to even want to rent this
now when it comes out aren't you
fascinated to see how okay it is who's
going to want to watch this now
i mean kind of if you just drop this on
streaming or on video on demand way more
people would have watched it
especially yeah you just do a vod
release even for a couple weeks just to
let people a few people pay for it and
then put it into disney plus or whatever
for their subscription fee
because this this three racks my whole
brain of every defense conversation or
optimistic conversation i've ever had
for this movie
of you know maybe they were just
delaying it because of that whole disney
fox merger and that was making things so
confusing so that's what it was right
that's what it had to be but then this
makes me go oh man did they delay it
because it's this bad
well darth phoenix was so horrible then
they're so
damnit yeah maybe they were like we
gotta get this out
in the quietest way possible put it in a
real movie theater we need a pandemic
183 people will see it and they'll be
the only user reviews on rotten tomatoes
it seems like they would have gotten
more eyeballs going with video on demand
and it almost now feels like they did
this yeah to just like really flop it
out there and get it out of the way
well guys are you gonna go watch the new
mutants you gonna drive to a drive-in
are you gonna to watch this really
darkly lit movie
and [ __ ] and your running lights
you can't turn those off it's not
available in your cause look at all
these other you
other than john campia but like merle's
in arkansas
i i forget where chris stuckman and
jeremy johns live but but they're not in
california
they live in a state where they can go
watch it well you know rb3 drove out to
somewhere to see tennant
so that sounds more worth it this yeah i
know and even that movie has gotten some
divisive responses but still
at least in a way that'll help man poor
movie
subscribe click that notification bell
and also we have some patrons that are
pledged to
our deleted take some behind the scenes
tier and they get a name call out every
month
so let's shout you mofos out let's do it
brittany
baierly joshua ruiz
body rot rogue cree
chrissy sam castle
deflated bradley sj94
andrew barber erwin rozier
rude rk deontay w aka tongue punch fart
box
kent mignolet kayla waters
justin martin anya r or or anja
canny waters or waters rosie baby
darth yoda order 66. roby baby
ruby james nobriga
josh philip j smith
jr jennifer smith
natalie doran marcus werderman gregory
bullock
eva drazdakova l
b michael o'hagan sean allen
wagner m tristan dale tiana
h patrick bagoon steven mendoza
and lucas romero give yourselves a round
of applause
pat yourselves on the back smooches to
you guys because
thank you thank you guys so much for
being here means a hell of a lot hope
you stay pledged
and uh we'll be posting a little bit
more on that tier soon thank you guys
look out
you